i've been studying work since the 1980s
and i've never seen anything like what's
happening today
pandemic fueled anxiety is surging
around the world in the u.s more than
half of all employees report feeling
stressed a lot of the day
job quits are at record levels running
at 4 million a month
people are burning out
in response a growing number of
companies are offering a four day
32 hour week
but with five days of pay
now it's not a new idea but the pandemic
has turbo charged it employers are
realizing that if they can rethink where
people work they can also rethink how
many days they're on the job
sound pretty great
but hmm is it realistic
well actually yes
unlike policies in which one party
profits at the expense of another the
four day week can benefit
workers companies and society
and it can even be a gateway for
addressing climate change
but first let's talk about the workplace
for nearly a decade
companies and governments have been
experimenting with shorter hours with no
cuts in pay
while the results do vary the research
shows that people are less stressed
value their jobs more and have better
lives outside of work
in most cases they are as productive in
four days as they are in five
companies can also see benefits through
lower turnover
and a higher quality applicant pool
less burnout reduces health care costs
mistakes and poor service
with colleagues i'm studying four-day
week trials now in progress in the
united states and ireland with summer
start dates for the uk new zealand and
australia we have thousands of employees
participating
health-wise an education company didn't
wait for a trial to begin
in june their employees were quitting in
droves
by august they'd implemented a four day
week
six months later ceo adam hussny reports
that people are dramatically happier and
have never been more productive
resignations and sick days are down
revenue has grown and customer
satisfaction scores are outstanding
health-wise employees are spending their
fridays off doing family activities like
sports or or errands
one mother of young children reported
that now she can occasionally manage a
guilt-free pedicure
the four-day week can help with
self-care and managing the daily
stresses of systemic racism sexism and
classism
now a key part of the model is that in
return for the gift of the day off
people are willing to squeeze all their
productivity into four days
so while they may be spending less time
at work they're not necessarily doing
less work
the secret sauce is work reorganization
cutting out the least productive
activities
meetings
are a prime target
most come yes i see everyone nodding
most companies reduce their frequency
and length and the number of attendees
at health-wise people save time by
messaging colleagues rather than making
phone calls which inevitably include
some social chatting
they shifted personal tasks like
doctor's appointments to the off day
and yes the pace of work at the office
does go up
let's be honest one explained i'm not
goofing off or looking at facebook which
i was
but people have adapted and they prefer
getting their down time as a whole day
off rather than in snippets
government initiatives have similar
findings in 2015 the city of reykjavik
and then the national government of
iceland
started offering 36 and 35 hour weeks
eventually enrolling more than 2500
employees
the results have been remarkable
physical and mental stress went down
while work ethic job satisfaction work
life balance energy levels all improved
productivity and service quality stayed
the same or got better
and the trial was revenue neutral
today
roughly 85 of all icelandic employees
are either on or eligible for these
schedules
the governments of spain and scotland
have announced four-day week trials in
which they'll be subsidizing the fifth
day's pay
now one reason for these successes is
that with reduced work time each hour
typically becomes more productive
norway and denmark the two european
countries with the shortest average
hours of work at about 1
380
have outsized productivity
france and germany are similar
in contrast the long hours countries
like
the uk and italy have
much much lower productivity
the u.s historically led the world in
productivity and would likely do better
now if its work time weren't so high
while tech firms comprise the biggest
group
adopting four day reduced hour schedules
companies are also making the switch in
banking pr marketing and design
non-profits consumer goods even a
restaurant chain
but it's also true that doing a hundred
percent of the work in eighty percent of
the time isn't feasible everywhere
manufacturing was sped up decades ago
many teachers and flight attendants need
to slow down not intensify
and of course health care workers on the
front lines of the pandemic
need to work less not more
here
yes
thank you health care workers
here another government effort is
instructive in 2014 the city of
gothenburg in sweden gave nurses at one
of its facilities a six-hour day
as expected the nurse's health and
overall well-being improved as did
productivity and patient care but in
this trial they hired new staff for the
hours that weren't being covered the
striking finding was how much lower sick
pay and unemployment benefits helped
offset those additional salaries
now the swedish case raises a bigger
more existential question
how much time
should we be dedicating to work
in many countries jobs are getting more
not less demanding and scarcity thinking
the idea that even rich countries need
to tighten their belts has taken hold
but really
we should be heading in the opposite
direction
as digitization and artificial
intelligence offer the chance to reduce
work time amid pandemic fatigue we
should be doubling down on restoring the
quality of life and our social fabric
especially in wealthy countries where we
already produce enough for everyone to
have a good standard of living
and this path
has the added benefit of addressing the
climate crisis
how so you may ask
well
with the four day week there's the
obvious impact of less commuting
but if we use productivity growth to
continue to reduce hours of work
just by a couple of percent a year
we can create a longer term dynamic of
decarbonization
research by me and others has shown this
time and again across countries across
states across
households
one reason
is that when people are time stressed
they tend to choose faster and more
polluting modes of travel and daily life
activities in contrast when people get
time rather than money
they tend to have a lower carbon
footprint
but the bigger reason has to do with the
size of the economy
by opting to work less countries are
choosing not to expand production to its
max thereby avoiding additional
emissions
carbon success stories like germany and
denmark tend to have low annual hours
france and the netherlands are also low
on both carbon and work time
the four day week is a down payment on a
new way to live and work
and yes we're going to need government
help if we're going to move beyond the
innovative companies that already see
its virtues
but as the three-day weekend spreads we
can realize
everyone deserves a right to free time
and that brings the logic of a universal
basic income squarely into view
because without financial support low
earners can't afford to take that fifth
day off
there's a lot of talk these days about
the future of work
and the opportunities that it offers
but there's more at stake here than
opportunity
we have an imperative
an imperative to face the challenges of
our current moment
the pandemic
burnout and depression
inequalities of race and income the
climate crisis
a four day week addresses each one of
these
for now we're starting company by
company
but as momentum builds and it becomes
universal will have made the transition
from scarcity thinking
to appreciating the true wealth that we
possess
our ingenuity
our compassion
and our humanity
thank you
julia thank you so much i have a very
practical question for you so you
mentioned in the talk that people were
taking friday off it is the is the
recommendation that people all take the
same day off or is this something that
people can take kind of any day they
went off like what's the what's the
ideal mechanism to have in place here
every company does it the way that works
for them and that's one of the things in
our trial we do coaching and we work
with the companies before they start to
figure out are they a company that can
shut down for one day do they need to
have 24 7 you know
customer service available so really it
depends and we're seeing every type
julia thank you so much thanks